coucou comment sarah comment est ce que
vous allez aujourd'hui j'espère que vous
allez bien ça devrait plutôt pas mal on
dit bien la maison les pédales vous
emmène à la maison pourquoi aujourd'hui
pour vous parler jusqu'à l'arrière moi
non pas du radiateur non pas très cher
mais pour vous parler de la télé qui est
juste derrière moi parce que aujourd'hui
c'est une vidéo qui est réalisé en
partenariat avec tcl pour vous présenter
un de leurs nouveaux téléviseurs de 2022
alors j'ai eu l'occasion il ya quelques
semaines d'aller chez tcl de découvrir
les nouveautés tcl du côté à des télés
c'est super intéressante et très belle
innovation narnia vous avez votre truc
est vraiment hyper cool pas si vous
connaissez tcl j'en ai déjà parlé tc on
a déjà regardé l'eau 10 euros l'année
dernière et puis tcl il ya plein de
produits pour la maison ce truc super
intéressant ce un très très gros
fabricant et un super fabricants
d'écrans et de dalles et aujourd'hui
justement on va se concentrer sur un
nouveau téléviseur 2022 tcl ça c'est un
65 pouces c'est qu l'aide militaire 144
hertz de taux de rafraîchissement bref
une vraie petite bombe pour la maison on
y va tout vous est pris vous êtes près
de 4
alors tu es si elle n'aime pas faire les
choses comme les autres on a des
nouvelles technologies ici c'est de la
mine il est c'est la quatrième
génération une télé que j'ai déjà
installé pas moi même tout seul balèze
ces deux-là 65 pouces croyez-moi faut
quand même y aller ils veulent pas qu à
plein son super intéressante au niveau
du design au niveau du pied central en
plus tcl fait comme je vous le disais
les choses pas comme les autres avec pas
moins de deux télécommandes une télé qui
a beaucoup de particularités qui va être
fait pour ceux qui veulent regarder la
télé sur année des films des séries
également pour les gamers pour ceux qui
veulent très bonne expérience audio
directement dans votre télé les
premières choses avant nous organiser
tous avant tout vous expliquer eh bien
on va commencer par faire un tour du
côté du design parce que l un design qui
est très sympa un peu différent et vous
allez voir franchement symbole du bois
la prendre la chose qui doit frapper
c'est les bords vous avait débord est
extrêmement fin sur le haut sur le bas
sur les côtés ça c'est un truc qui est
vraiment très très très cool parce que
ça apporte vraiment de la légèreté à
votre téléviseur dans votre intérieur ça
évite d'abord un truc un petit peu trop
lourd que ce soit sous 10 sur le haut
sur le banc et autre point qui est
extrêmement important vous devriez tout
de suite c'est le pied central alors ça
c'est chouette parce que on est quand
même sur une télé de 65 pouces que j'ai
ici qui existent également en 55 et en
75 ça veut dire qu'elle est quand même
relativement grande relativement longue
ça dépend l'intérieur allez si je recule
un petit peu plus aller voir chez moi
bon ça va ça convient on radiateur qui
met un peu le bazar mais sinon au delà
de ça ça va parfaitement bien à 65 j'ai
plutôt l'habitude des 55-65 va très très
bien la faire mais le fait d'avoir un
petit centrale comme ça ça apporte quoi
eh bien ça apporte tout simplement que
vous allez pouvoir avoir différents
meubles différentes longueurs de meubles
pour autant c'est une télé vous pouvez
également venir à fixer sur un mur si
vous souhaitez donc elle a plein
davantage on a les bords fins elle est
très légère on a le pied central qui est
hyper canon et en plus ça n'est pas
extrêmement épaisse d'aller voyez comme
ça m'a vexé quand même relativement fin
et que je trouve pour ma part super
élégant on a donc un design extrêmement
premium dans ce téléviseur qui
conviendra je dire à beaucoup
d'intérieur je vous dis 55 65 75 mousse
ça c'est cool et la référence je donne
parce qu'elle fait à noter c'est la tcl
ça c'est 65 65 ses 80 3 83 c'est le
modèle 5 x 1 ce qu'on appellera la tcl
ses 83 mais cette tcl ses 83 elle a
beaucoup d'avantagés mais alors beaucoup
davantage premier avantage c'est la
technologie qui a été choisi au niveau
de ce téléviseur on est sur une télé qu
aide jusque là ça va c'est du quantum
dots le culex est bien connu mais vous
avez pas des led vous avez des mini
l'aide ça veut dire qu'en fait j'ai peur
des lettres qui vont être beaucoup plus
réduit de beaucoup plus de petite taille
et vous avez plus de 1000 zone
différente au niveau de vos mini l'aide
et qu'est ce que ça vient apporter la
mini l'aide par rapport à la led et bien
comme vous avez des leds beaucoup plus
petit et ciel qui vont apporter la
lumière et bien ça vous apporter
beaucoup plus de détails et ça s'est
super bien très belle luminosité très
belles couleurs également ici la
technologie miled vous permet d'avoir un
rétro éclairage direct avec plusieurs
zones 2000 est qu'ils vont être
contrôlés indépendamment les unes des
autres ça vous apportera plus de détails
dans les zones sombres une optimisation
des contrastes une très bonne luminosité
puis des noirs profonds tout s'accoupler
avec de la capca hdr premium 1500 et
surtout et je vous disais tout à l'heure
un taux de rafraîchissement variable 244
m alors pour autant rassurez vous si
vous allez regarder quelque chose en 50
et 60 hertz en herbe 120 hertz il n'y a
aucun problème ça va s'adapter ce qu'on
appelle du vrs et du var yembeul refresh
weight donc ça va jusqu'à 144 hertz mais
vous n'allez pas avoir du 144 hertz en
permanence pour ça va dépendre de la
source et de ce qui va rentrer sur votre
téléviseur mais ce qui est super c'est
qu'on peut monter jusqu'à 144 hertz ce
qu'ils appellent le 144 alerte clarity
pro mais ça ne s'arrête pas là
puisqu'elle est compatible hd r10 plus
dolby lisions et dolby vision itunes ça
vous permettra quoi ça et bien que votre
téléviseur va venir s'adapter à la
lumière ambiante voyez par exemple de
suite jour il ya ici des baies vitrées
il ya beaucoup de lumière qui rentre et
bien elle elle va capter ça elle va
venir s'adapter et lorsque vous êtes et
bien j'en sais rien la nuit ou qui a
beaucoup moins de lumière là également
venir s'adapter pour vous est toujours
la meilleure expérience possible
directement ici sur votre tv ça c'est
très bien alors tout ça ça apporte un
vrai bénéfice tout ce que vous me
regardez des films une série lorsque
vous êtes sur netflix sur dix n'est plus
surpris vidéo avec les abonnements les
plus hauts bien évidemment pour venir
profiter une super expérience en 4k ça
c'est très bien mais pour guy mixer
aussi vachement bien pourquoi parce
qu'ici vous montez en 4k 120 hertz sans
aucun problème vous avez plusieurs ports
hdmi je voulais me retrouve quelques
instants mais vous avez notamment du
hdmi 2.1 donc ça c'est vachement bien
avec un input lag qui va être inférieure
à 6 millisecondes et vous avez le à llm
ces lotos low latency mode à ce qui
permet effectivement d'avoir cette
latence très faible lorsque vous allez
venir jouer à différents jeux on a le
free 5 premium et on a également la
barre de jeter ciel d'un point de vue
logiciel donc on a tout ce qu'il faut
ici pour profiter d'une très bonne
expérience lorsqu'on vient jouer alors
moi je ne suis pas gamers et pas de
console qui ne fait pas bien branché et
vous montrer mais en tout cas ici ce
qu'on voit c'est que tu essaies elle
montre les muscles pour avoir une telle
équivoque je dirais à 360 degrés pour
dire draguer différentes personnes on
peut bien draguer à la fois ce qui va
regarder des films des séries les gamer
mais également ceux qui aiment la
musique oui pourquoi grâce au système
audio vous avez des hauts parleurs signé
onkyo et vous avez un petit caisson de
basses qui à l'arrière je vais vous
montrer ça c'est intéressant vous avez 2
x 15 watts plus 30 watts au niveau des
caissons menace est bien évidemment en
plus adéquat vous avez du dolby atmos
alors le dolby atmo ça va servir à quoi
ça va servir un peu à élargir
l'expérience à venir vous envelopper
lorsque vous êtes face à votre
téléviseur que vous ayez l'impression
que le som viennent autour de vous un
peu tous les côtés comme si vous aviez
un système de diffusion multi points
sans en avoir un donc ça c'est plutôt
aussi très intéressant puisque avec une
seule source qui est là ça va venir vous
immerger dans votre film d'embouts de
jeu dans votre série dont tout ce que
vous voulez vous manque les connectiques
regardez ici là vous avez de lui mais à
2.0 pour venir vous branchez si besoin
est un petit rj45 alors en dessous là
vous avez deux hdmi 4 k 144,4 casse on
va à m on va avoir ensuite les entrées
câble les entrées satellite si on le
souhaite on va avoir ensuite une sortie
optique j'ai en dessous deux autres hdmi
la cdu 4k 60 c'est également du 4k 60 en
dessous ça c'est de l'itrc ensuite j'ai
une sortie av et une sortie jack ou la
brancher un casque ici si on le souhaite
puisque je suis à l'arrière jean
professeur c'est vachement intéressant
vous voyez vous avez votre caisson de
basses qui est ici onkyo ultra bas si
vous voulez crif donc le petit caisson
de basses il est là alors il ya un truc
qui est assez malin c'est le passage de
call comme vous êtes sur un pied central
tout passe par le centre de l'autre côté
ici assez mon alimentation électrique
que j'ai fait arriver directement là et
que je passe par là mais si je venais
branche est bien une console une box ou
tout ce que je voulais et bien je peux
venir prendre et si je le fais courir
derrière et je le mets là et après le
passage de cabasse est extrêmement
simple j'ai juste enlever le cash est
située juste la voilà j'enlève le cash
j'ai mon passage de câbles j'ai
également le petit passage la voyez qui
est au centre ça vient vraiment me le
prendre ça je peux venir rassembler tous
mes câble au centre mais c'est
extrêmement pratique et de la même
manière et vous le voyez là elle est
très facile à monter parce que pour le
montage j'ai deux vis à poser là haut de
mon téléviseur ici j'en ai trois ans bat
pour venir le sertit enfin le relier à
la plaque y ait ici donc j'ai la plaque
j'ai cet élément central qui vient faire
le lien entre le téléviseur et le pied
enfin l'élément central de pied qui est
posée juste leur donc ça c'est aussi
très facile à venir installer autre
élément qui est hyper intéressant ici
avec ce téléviseur c'est qu'on est sur
google tv ouais alors google tv ça viens
vous apporter quoi et bien google tv en
fait c'est dès aujourd'hui la meilleure
expérience qu'on va venir retrouver sur
téléviseur pourquoi alors bien
évidemment et point compte derrière
pouvoir profiter de l'expérience mais ça
fait quoi en fait si vous voulez c'est
l'idée 1 de google c'est qu'ils viennent
connaître vos goûts vos habitudes et
viennent vous suggérez du contenu sur
toutes les plateformes c'est tout
l'intérêt de nouvelles tv aujourd'hui
c'est à dire que pourriez je vais avoir
le pouls vous c'est à dire tout ce qu'on
va venir me suggérer et une collègue au
google donc il sait à peu près ce que
j'aime ready pays roide j'adore ce film
la frêle j'ai beaucoup aimé tôt qu'elle
ne me proposait différents films sur
différentes plateformes saas et du
disney plus seul abonnement à disney +
disney + prime vidéo j'ai également un
abonnement chez prime minority report
j'ai adoré il est chez prime ils
voyaient disney plus et j'ai pas vu de
netflix mais pour autant mon et le flic
c'est bien ici à la petite sirène moyens
gérard délatté de sirène live irobot
j'adore également et robben donc là
c'est toute la suggestion qui est fait
par rapport à vos goûts et par rapport à
ce que vous regardez mais pas uniquement
sur google mais également sur toutes les
plateformes alors après vous retrouvé
vos différentes applications netflix
youtube disney plus près une vidéo mais
canal molotov tous les abonnements que
j'ai ça france tv tcl chanel également
salto youtube qu'ils bref la musique est
tout à fait chez vous en avez d'autres
et après vous avez des séries et des
films populaires pourrait venir louer si
besoin en plus à voir pourquoi pas et
puis après gardez vous avez là plein de
choses on avoue proposés par différentes
catégories sur des films d'action film
avec oscar film de science-fiction
j'adore la science fiction est plus
qu'une call est vachement bien des films
d' aventure des films d'espionnage vous
voyez vous allez tous avoir un contenu
qui va être personnalisé en fonction de
ce que vous allez pouvoir regarder
directement et des abonnements que vous
avez donc c'est très très chouette c'est
tout l'intérêt aujourd'hui d'avoir
google tv ici directement pour trouver
tout votre contenu tout en sachant qu'en
plus et c'est l'intérêt ici vous allez
pouvoir venir le piloter à la voie alors
pour autant ici tcl nous a mis deux
télécommandes et on va regarder on va
comprendre pourquoi non quelques
instants mais l'idée c'est que vous
venez directement pilotés votre
téléviseur à la bois grâce à l'assistant
vocal quel temps fait-il à paris
aujourd'hui
donc bref vous voyez donc on peut
retrouver notre assistant on va pouvoir
lui demander à d'allumer les lumières
d'éteindre les lumières de venir gérer
plein de choses à la maison donc c'est
intéressant parce que votre télé
l'élément central comme chez google on
peut venir lui faire faire plein de
choses lui demander plein de choses
c'est extrêmement pratique et puis tu ça
ne s'arrête pas là parce que vous avez
aussi google bio alors il faut venir
ajouter une petite caméra sur le dessus
que vous n'avez pas ici mais si vous
voulez le faire venir a ajouté une
petite caméra et pouvoir utiliser votre
téléviseur pour venir à converser avec
la famille à distance se voir faire des
meetings avec plein de personnes
directement donc ça aussi c'est très
sympa et c'est tout l'intérêt
aujourd'hui d'une expérience comme
celle-là à google tv où on voit qu'on a
un google qui vous connaît également sur
vos goûts à la télé tu vas venir vous
proposer des contenus que vous dire
maintien je sais que tu aimes tel film
et bastien il était le jour à tel
endroit pour faire plein de choses donc
ça c'est chouette et c'est une superbe
expérience au niveau de la télé c'est
une évolution par rapport à android tv
c'est beaucoup plus complexe si vous
voulez vraiment une tv intelligente à
des google tv intégré ici vous avez ce
qu'il faut moi je vous le disais tout à
l'heure on va venir se poser maintenant
la question des télécommandes pourquoi
est-ce que tu essaies elle nous met deux
télécommandes elles sont livrées et
coûte pas plus cher vous avez les deux
et elles sont fournies directement
dedans je voulais présenter et puis on
va essayer de comprendre un peu ce qui
se passe derrière tout ça première
télécommande c'est celle là c'est une
télécommande je dirais un peu plus
standard vous allez retrouver votre
bouton pour l'élu mais pour l'éteindre
le nude et puis ensuite les petits
boutons pour venir changer de chaîne la
liste mon le programme montel sont
baissées leçon la commande pour naviguer
des petits codes couleurs sympathique le
plat est posé compagnie puis en dessous
à me dire trouver des raccourcis netflix
et prennent vie des ossis une
télécommande très classique on connaît
ce genre télécommande on a tous eu il ya
très longtemps ils vous invitent
d'ailleurs probablement aujourd'hui et
ça nous emmène la deuxième télécommande
qui elle est gérée la télécommande vous
allez probablement utilisé plus même si
celle là c'est qu'elle a un petit côté
rassurant avec ses petits numéros mais
on s'en fiche c'est vraiment celle là
qui va bien nous intéresser et pourquoi
le regarde et on fait un petit tour vous
allez comprendre déjà on va retrouver un
bouton pour mieux allumer pour
l'éteindre lemieux août l'assistant
vocal qui se situe à bout ils
permettront pas ça un petit bouton pour
venir naviguer à directement hockey ici
le menu principal de retour en arrière
montée des cils volume les petits
programmes ici je sais votre source bref
il ya plein de petits boutons et puis on
trouve surtout vous avez plein de
raccourcis netflix prennent video awards
média youtube tcl chanel et si vous
voulez en fait c'est tellement logique
en fait tcl nouve deux télécommandes
pour qui eh bien je dirais que la
première c'est un peu pour rassurer la
ménagère anguilles mais quand je dis ça
c'est pour rassurer monsieur et madame
tout le monde qui se disent mais attends
je comprends pas j'ai pas mes boutons
j'ai besoin de ça mais on va se rendre
compte que le temps passant que cette
télécommande la rendre plus trop utilisé
et on va utiliser celle là pourquoi
parce que c'est google tv parce que
l'idée d'un label tv c'est de ne pas
venir utiliser à vos petites chaînes un
peu de ton art comme ça c'est que vous
n'avez plus besoin de ça pour quoi on
réfléchit au niveau des usages le
premier usage c'est qu'on va venir
l'utilisé beaucoup à voir ok mais moi
telle chaîne mais moi tel programme les
mois telles séries du 100m en mémoire
friends mais moi j'en sais rien moi game
of thrones tout ce que vous voulez et
google tv est intelligent il va le faire
alors il faut les abonnements attention
si vous l'avez les cameron et vous
n'avez pas l'abonnement c est ça ne
marchera pas si vous voulez regarder
j'en sais rien moi n'importe quelle
série sur prime ou sur des flics mais si
vous n'avez pas l'abonnement ça ne
servirait à rien même si vous avez les
petits boutons ici donc de toutes façons
il vous faudra l'abonnement mais dès
lors vous avez les abonnements derrière
et bientôt de tv va vous emmener
directement donc on va même se passer de
sa porte d'affaires à la voie en gros
l'idée si vous vois venir lui parler et
venir tous pilotés à la voix même avec
le petit mot magique que vous connaissez
tous et si je le dis je souhaite servir
déclenchait des choses si vous donc de
près par nos envoyés à ces pratiques
déjà c'est le premier point et puis le
deuxième point c'est comme vous allez
venir allumé et activer directement vos
programmes à l'avoir bien vous n'avez
pas besoin de ces touches là et alors si
ça vous rassure vous avez quand même
tous les raccourcis en bas ou alors le
petit bouton home pour arriver dessus
donc en fait on n'a plus besoin de ces
grosse télécommande un peu à l'ancienne
tout ont été soit sûr de la tnt ou soit
sur du hertzien quand on remonte un peu
plus longtemps à venir appuyer sur le
bouton ici on est dans une autre ère et
celle là où nous emmène google tv mais
également tcl commandes vocales plus de
boutons et je suis même sûr qu'un jour a
encore aujourd'hui mais un jour
probablement tcl eh bien nous emmènera à
carrément supprimer les télécommandes
comme ça on n'aura plus besoin tous fera
au niveau de la voix peut-être pour
configurer jean sarrailh un minima mais
ça ça peut vraiment être amené à
disparaître donc voyez en fait c'est de
télécommande on les a pour venir
rassurer pour venir s'adapter à tout le
monde parce que comme je vous disais que
ce téléviseur d'un téléviseur qui est
exigeante qui a des specs des specs
gonflé mais qui est là pour tout le
monde que vous vouliez un film une série
une telle un peu classique brancher le
câble le satellite et la tnt et que vous
ayez une playstation 5 ou une xbox je
sais pas quoi vous allez mettre dessus
jouer dans les meilleures conditions
regarder des films et des séries en
super qualité en 4k ici avec un taux de
rafraîchissement qui pèsent jusqu'à 144
ans avec de la mini l'aide de quatrième
génération avec du pull est bref un truc
est vachement bien mais pts et couleurs
contraste vous avez une télé qui est
super intéressante et surtout le tarif
vous donnent-ils et l'arrêt des
pratiques locales et gilles tarifs
1490 euros autant dire que le tarif ans
mais quelles seront les héros c'est une
somme à même pour voir ce que vous avez
et fille en termes de mini l'est et
quand tout le dot et compagnie vous avez
vraiment un tarif qui est hyper canon
d'ailleurs si elle vous intéresse et
bien évidemment je voulais un lien en
bas dans la description et j'ai une
super nouvelle pour vous cette télé elle
est à gagner ouais c'est très facile
alors pour participer je vous mets tous
les détails juste en bas dans la
description vous n'avez plus qu'à
regarder et vous allez voir c'est très
facile pour dire tenter votre chance et
potentiellement gagner ce téléviseur
vous allez voir c'est plutôt chouette
maintenant je sais pas ce que vous en
pensez vous est-ce que vous connaissiez
déjà testé alors si vous regardez ma
chaîne régulièrement probablement vous
connaissez pas ce que j'en ai déjà parlé
jeudi notamment sur le 10 02 l'année
dernière et je vous invite à aller jeter
un coup d'oeil parce qu'en termes de
technologie c'est juste énorme et puces
slc une marque qui innovent énormément
avec de très très beau téléviseur très
belle dalle extrêmement bien maîtrisé à
vous mettez à dos ce que vous en pensez
en bas en commentaire comment vous la
trouverez ce téléviseur je rappelle la
référence une fois de plus c'est la tcl
65 c
83,5 plutôt super bon moi j'adore j'aime
beaucoup ce téléviseur je trouve
intéressant le design est chouette fait
d'avoir pied central c'est hyper cool
vous aviez super techno d'affichage
super techno audio très bon son avec le
caisson de basses à l'arrière qui va
venir vous apporter un peu plus de
rondeur à venir envoyer du bois pour le
gaming c'est top bref fiche technique
très musclé tarif super intéressant donc
très très belle proposition tcl a vous
de me dire ce que vous en pensez en bas
en commentaire merci à tcl d'avoir
contourné cette vidéo où l'on se
retrouve très vite pour continuer à
parler de quoi appareil bien sûr voilà
bisous des bateaux bisous à bientôt des
maisons faisant face aux niçois de
soutien
[Musique]